el banco de Inglaterra pronosticó a
principios de este mes que la inflación
del Reino Unido alcanzaría un máximo de
alrededor del 11% en el cuarto trimestre
la tasa de inflación interanual de
octubre está un poco por encima de esa
cifra en el 11,1 el nuevo Primer
Ministro británico richiesunak en su
intervención en el g20 de Bali en
Indonesia culpó de las tensiones
económicas directamente a la guerra de
Vladimir Putin en Ucrania
deberíamos ser claros nada de esto
estaría ocurriendo si no fuera por la
invasión de Rusia a Ucrania Esta es la
cruel e implacable realidad de la guerra
de Putin y mientras continúen seguirá
devastando la economía mundial
los precios de los alimentos en el Reino
Unido subieron varios puntos por encima
de la tasa de inflación General ya que
los supermercados trasladaron el aumento
de Los costos a los consumidores el
precio de la electricidad y el gas
natural también fue significativamente
superior al Reino Unido le va peor que a
la mayoría de los países en lo que es
una tendencia mundial la directora
general de la Organización Mundial del
Comercio en declaraciones a France 24
durante la Cumbre del g20 en Bali afirmó
que la guerra en Ucrania ha exacerbado
una serie de factores que alimentan la
inflación
tuvimos la pandemia tuvimos el estímulo
fiscal tuvimos mucha demanda el sistema
creo que es más productivo intentar
averiguar Cómo frenar esta inflación que
entrar en un juego de culpas
mientras el Reino Unido espera las
medidas presupuestarias clave el jueves
otros países observarán como sus tasas
de inflación continúan al alza